I have an infamous picture of me in my
20s and I was just owning this look I
had a turtleneck
I had mom jeans on I was wearing a fat
goodbye I think we've got the picture
hell no this was you being serious yeah
no oh yes I think I'm cool and are you
aware that this has now become a sort of
fancy dress outfit people do this they
do this yeah yeah as a joke Seth Rogen
was on the show yeah and he showed us
his version here Seth Rogen as it
actually some other people have done it
as well yeah check this out
[Applause]
you had the topknot they go lovely burn
that's always a practical it's not that
it's fine
this one okay what was going on here
that was maybe a bad decision yeah it
was a bad time in his world because I
was actually going to South Africa at
the time with England and I ended up
meeting Nelson Mandela I know you did
and and the pictures that's why I regret
that the madness won the most um David
Beckham look I think is this one doesn't
seem like you at all big smiley face
there no well I don't know why I had
that one when you decided to move away
from PJ & Duncan and become Ant & Dec
rebrand yourself as active dick you went
through a sort of makeover didn't you a
kind of extreme makeover yeah yes yeah
we did but it wasn't our idea but we
yeah we wanted to ditch the name's PJ
and don't gonna be come on and debt our
real names yeah so I think was Smash
Hits magazine so you should do like an
image makeover why don't you do that so
it'll work really well yeah yeah so
unsaid I've shaved my head okay I don't
really gonna do that I look silly like
that so I'll dye my hair
so the idea was to dye my hair blonde up
but it just went ginger
what I mean was it wasn't quite the look
we were going for so this is the cover
you've got it's there it's vibrant
yellow that what I would say is though
so that happened and you obviously saw
that in vibrant color understand you
then did a shoot for a gay magazine
attitude yeah and you thought we can
tone this down and sex it up what this
is on the bottom there there there oh
yeah and add a [ __ ] saloon or in your
hair
in clay and then there is a brilliant
picture inside this is Gillian no don't
worry aunt you're safe this is this is
dick and they want to know what the
instruction was what the photographer
said today but he must said oh you're in
a gay magazine do something that will
really appeal to the game
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
and job
to the dolphin I am 26 in that picture
and I thought it was a great idea to put
on a gray wig and old lady glasses I'm
like sure who wouldn't hire her hire her
before this next woman you thought about
but you yeah you do a lot of material
about growing up a nerd but you really
weren't yeah no I really was we've got
photographic evidence there you go this
will prove it haircut was done by
folding my face in half that was yeah
that was something that I knew I needed
was headshots everyone says you needed
shots and so I was on the hunt for
headshots but I was completely broke and
I was I was at the post office in West
Hollywood which is a an area in LA
that's like a predominantly gay area and
I was there getting Hegg getting like
picnic
[Applause]
I know I saw this this guy was like was
had this look he was like like he
recognized me I was like hello he was
like you look familiar have I shot you I
was like I've never been shot you shot
me and he was like Nam do you model I'm
a photographer do you model and I was
like no but I need have you ever heard
of headshots
I need something called headshots I was
20 years old and the guy was like I do
headshots I live like two blocks from
here no I'll give you headshots I was
like well what does it cost he's like
just cut it's fine I'll cover you I was
like oh sweet okay let's go I go to this
guy's apartment he lived on the top
floor really nice apartment
amazing furnishings
he was like listen you probably a little
grimy probably need a shower I was like
that so really good idea shower tons of
good soaps and probably needed a shower
and then he was like hmm you should you
should probably wear some different
clothes so he gives me like this
nice nice white shirt there's a polo
shirt a nice shirt and and kind of like
helps me and like judges me up and stuff
and we go out on the balcony and and he
takes like a bunch of photos and he's
like directing me and telling me what to
do and he takes all these photos and
takes the film out of the camera and he
puts it in the film thing and he just
gives it to me and he was like there you
go and I just walked out and I was like
yeah that stick to that story
[Applause]
that's silence the audience look at my
hair that was a guy who clearly couldn't
afford a haircut let alone a headshot I
don't know that I ever saw him again I
if you're watching thank you for my head
shots he's probably making money of
those pictures he took a view in the
shower
[Applause]
[Music]